where's Vegas biggest song Ray J's
biggest song is a sexy cannot just buh
hey what's going on rolls it's Sean
Evans this is empty calories and this is
my co-host and Sund
le ly the only person I know who watches
more TV than I do
Sean thank you so much for having me I'm
so excited to be here and the ethical
arrangement do you can just walk the
fruit oh well no one has to do that but
is it good now for a couple hours right
so so anyway John as you know food has
permeated every corner of pop culture
and me we know that you don't have time
to sift through all that content so me
and wanted it for you the cooking shows
that you miss Carolina Reeperbahn grits
Gordon Ramsay melt down Bobby Flay
dancing the Big Pun Giada's cleavage
immaculate cleavage but without further
[ __ ] around Jackson Wilson clips I
want to talk about my woman crush
everyday Rachael Ray and I think that
when people think about Rachael Ray in
the Rachael Ray Show they think about
cooking tutorial right but when you have
an hour of programming to fill sometimes
you can end up with some pretty bizarre
segments Oh a mom in the audience has a
question about hemorrhoids let's see how
that goes
so what happens is we have a little
demonstration any increased pressure is
going to be transmitted to the vessels
at the end of our rectum and Hemel is
come in two flavors they come in
internal and external hemorrhoid
finished flavors were you uncomfortable
throughout this thing so I would say no
I think you know that guy's got the
tennis ball holder out and he's got like
this thing the pencil I think was the
[ __ ] and so it was pumping the
[ __ ] opens up and in out and I think
that was a less low in saying yeah and I
think hands doing it was was the
hemorrhoids coming in so that was like
an insane swelling situation I love a
butthole on daytime TV during the
cooking kitchen Food Show right
using after like the blog hole
hemorrhoid segment they went straight
into like a cooking like how to cook
nacho segments you would think so huh
but no I wash my belly button but I also
notice a funny smell when you have a
foul smell coming from it if it's been
there for a long time and you're not
cleaning properly you can actually have
up to 67 different types of bacteria
accumulate in there Wow well the whole
internet is running around talking about
this salt bay guy there is Loki a rick
ross documentary about how he's
investing in a checkers franchise that
deserves all the eyeballs number one
bird you in the game [ __ ]
number one french fries in the gaming Oh
Rick Ross is like I just wanted to say
that if he's always scared me you know
like for me to be decided it almost
makes me feel like he's very likable my
favorite thing about Rick Ross and this
particular clip is the melodrama is he
announcing an album is it a single is it
label news yeah is it a new signing is
there a new artist that he wants to
present to the world this was big thing
yeah and then he's like you know 20
years now I can get whatever I want and
it's like his career is sort of
culminating and the fact that he now has
a checkers in Florida the boss chick
young thug's Wyclef Jean video comes out
and it seems like the director was dealt
kind of a bad hand you know a young thug
he didn't show up when he was supposed
to show up he had to splice together
footage as he was able to make it happen
he tells the whole story within the
video but the standout moment for my
money
the only footage that this director had
to work with that featured young thug
was young thug outside of the private
jet just sort of casually snacking on
Cheetos young thugs only lids on ready
Funyuns great choice of snacks gummy
worms fan or your fans gummy worms local
okay I'm not really and vending machine
hot fries love them
think about his most iconic moments
usually they involve snacks and the one
that stands out to me and it's the best
one is when it was at the airport in the
wheelchair casually snacking on vanilla
wafers this whole with West Coast run
turned oh so much hey Ellie
even vape this is stoner snacks dining
and dabbing so apparently it's now a
bubbling trend at a Korean barbecue
restaurant to dab while you're having
your dinner and because there's so much
smoke somewhere else in the restaurant
you a don't have to worry about
disturbing your neighbors it's masked
and you don't have to worry about
getting caught because there's smoke all
over the place whose - no whose dabbing
and who's cooking and it wasn't we
smokers are always thinking innovative
ways how can we get away with it how can
we get high during every moment of our
life you know it definitely defies the
stereotype yes so we're trying it that
was heated that was heated and it's
about to get even more heated so much
more has written of a food fight - that
sector Schoenberger the first piece just
released an article of top-15 fries in
America and Arby's with number one
definitely a curveball but that's okay
because that's not my number one that's
not your number one and our what it's
Justin what the [ __ ] dude but anyway
you're gonna ride with your favorite
fries which are Burger King yeah I'm
riding with my favorite fries which are
McDonald's
take your position okay first of all I
know that I don't have the most popular
opinion the Burger King fries yo they
were peppered they were crunchy man I
would eat those five all day every day
over McDonald any day to me McDonald's
has such range now sometimes you go in
there and you get the old bottom of the
barrel size that look like lo mein
noodles and they just end up between
your car seats where they stay for 25
years and those are the worst but you
know what the best of McDonald's when
those things are hot to the touch they
leave a little oil on your fingers when
they're not overly salted I think that
they're the best fries I've ever had in
my life I know that on every list
everyone always as McDonald's
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah sometimes it's
just true sometimes it just is number
one okay
McDonald's is number one Sean I wanna
speak until I have appear that's about
to drop that mean that one well that's a
wrap for episode 1 of empty calories
check back with us next Tuesday for more
clips more heated debates more edible
arrangements i'm sean evans Nilan we'll
try to do better next time
[Music]
Carolina Reaper bong rich just say
Carolina Reaper long rip Carolina Reaper
bong hits
rip rip ah when a [ __ ] guy can you
write it Carolina Reaper bong rips